can you describe to me if it's useful at
all to know the difference
if there's a difference between white
nationalism white supremacism
and uh Christian nationalism
is there an intersection between them
I've I've heard these terms used oh
separatism too right that
um is there interesting distinction that
permeated that history that's the last
today I I think um there's a long
history in the United States of a belief
in white supremacy and it's not unique
to the United States we actually inherit
this from Europe uh and white supremacy
is is the belief that uh for whatever
reason those with lighter color skin uh
usually of northern European extraction
uh are superior have more rights or the
better people to make decisions all
sorts of things and it's an aesthetic
judgment as much as it is a political
judgment and that gets embedded in our
society right we inherit that
um Christian nationalism
is the presumption that is not just your
race but now it's also your Christian
belief and that is actually relatively
new there are little pieces of that in
our history but but many of those who
are white supremacists even those in the
Confederacy are not Christian
nationalists because they don't agree on
which kind of Christianity and they
don't view those who are from a
different denomination of Christianity
of being good Christians there isn't
this big tent Christianity in the 19th
century
um this notion that there is one
Christian Nation and that we're all part
of it that's actually really a 20th
century creation it precedes the
Evangelical movement but it's been made
even more popular but it would not make
sense to a Confederate to say we're a
right white Christian Nation it would
make sense to say we're a white
Protestant Nation because they didn't
consider Catholics good Christians or a
white Presbyterian Nation
um and so that's that's something new
and I think what's particularly
dangerous about this notion of Christian
nationalism is it creates this false
history saying we've always been
together as Christians that's always how
we've denied I defined ourselves and
that's not accurate well one interesting
thing so I recently talked to
uh uh left leaning or maybe a far left
political streamer Named Destiny uh
Stephen Bonnell I don't know if you're
familiar with him he uh he does uh live
streaming debates with people it's very
passionate I've heard of this my
students have told me I'm not actually
my students are always up on the most
hip things yes that is no no the funny
thing about him he's already considered
like a boomer he's already the old
streamer because he's been doing it for
10 years he's not the cool kids anymore
anyway he goes into some difficult
political territory and he actually had
a many conversation with Nick Fuentes
and he says I mean uh some of it is
humor but some of it is pretty dark uh
hard-hitting sort of criticism is he
says that anyone who claims to be a
Christian nationalist asks them if they
would rather have a million people who
are atheists from Sweden who are white
come or if you would rather have a
million uh people from Africa who are
Christian come and the the truth comes
out that this is a very surface level
this kind of idea of Christian
nationalism is still underneath it is a
deep racism uh like hatred towards black
people I think that's I'm sure that's
right I'm sure that's right that's the
sense I got into it does not seem to
have deep kind of uh yeah like
historical context to it it's just it's
just a different every branding of the
old kind of hate what I think is
important though in drawing this
distinction and why it really matters
beyond the history of it is someone like
Lincoln
quotes scripture all the time the second
inaugural is filled second inaugural
address the Gettysburg Address filled
with Biblical references
but he does it in a way that's not
Christian nationalist because he's using
the text to bring people together he's
using it as a fable of humanity
and you could say he's not open to
Islamic thinking he's ignorant of the
Islamic world but as a Jew I'm a Jew
reading and studying Lincoln I know he's
a Christian but I don't feel excluded
from his rhetoric
because I share that Bible
we have different views but I I don't
feel excluded it actually brings people
together the Christian nationalist
approach that we've seen in the 20th
century and especially in recent decades
is intended to divide people
it excludes Jews
it excludes Christians who don't
interpret Christianity their way and and
to say that's what we've always done is
an entire Distortion of our country
and it also hides why this is so
dangerous
insofar as Christianity matters to our
country it should be in the way Lincoln
uses it as a set of common texts that
many of us resonate with knowing that we
have different rituals and different
understandings not as a way to exclude
people and not as a cover for racism
which is what it is it's kind of
interesting that you could talk about
I've talked to a lot of people Muslim
folks uh Jewish folks Christian folks
there's a way to talk about religion
that's inclusive and then that's
exclusive I mean it's just been of these
I've been listening to a lot of these
Interfaith conversations and they're
awesome
they like celebrate the beauty of each
religion they banter and argue with each
other about details and so on but like
it feels like love like it feels like
anybody from any of those religions uh
would feel welcome at that party yeah
and I think that's possible